Well this sounds like
it's a very complex
collection of technologies
that you have.
But I understand that you've developed
a novel approach to architecting
these applications called layer blocks.
Could you tell us a little bit about
what motivated you to do this?
>> Sure, so thus far, we've talked
largely about kind of how the high-level
deployment architecture of the system
works and what makes it interesting.
But I've been pretty abstract
with respect to the code itself.
And what gets loaded
into those databases.
You may recall at the beginning I
was saying that one thing that makes
our company a little different and our
technologies stacked a little different
is that we actually install
code into the databases, and
you can think of those databases as
being active rather than passive.
Their actively calculating and
coming up with results rather
than just being dumb date stores.
So that code that we write and
install on those databases itself has
some interesting software engineering
challenges because we implement all of
the business rules in our applications,
in that code, and then install it.
And one of the things we've found is
that particularly with applications,
like forecast managers and most of the
other predictive applications that we're
developing, is that we are often are not
developing just a single product, but
in fact, we are often developing
something more akin to a product line.
That is we find that there are many
slightly different variances of
use of the same algorithm
like forecasting.
But they need to be deployed
in slightly different ways for
slightly different contexts.
And so, what motivated Layer Blocks was,
after we had been doing some
development on the first
Forecast Manager application, we noticed
that a lot of the work we were doing was
kind of developing code that
really seemed redundant.
That we're developing the same kinds
of algorithms multiple times for
these different uses.
And we wanted to find
a way to unify that, so
we could do the development once,
very efficiently, and
manage this growing list of variants
of the same component or functionality.
>> So this is getting back to
the challenge you mentioned at the start
about that each customer has
their own specific needs, okay.
But that you'd like,
to the extent possible,
to have a common solution to reduce your
costs of dealing with the customers.
>> Exactly.
Yeah, you don't want to have to develop
a system, a component from scratch for
each customer.
If you've got 100 customers, you don't
want to have to develop 100 components.
And what you want to do is you want to
develop one component very nicely so
that it can be configured and
packaged in different ways very easily.
And that's what we
developed LayerWise for.